yeah I kept to this video playing dalvik
from Germany yeah let's let's play the
bank owned and I always give the Banco
some bad so bad reviews here on this
channel for some reason it's not a bad
opening but it's not easy to play let's
see what happens here seems we get the
field chateau now it doesn't seem that
it is the via chat online not ft7
deserve an idea that there recently as
saw in a book so i was some time going
for that but of course i'm no expert on
the panko
yeah not sure I know that age 4 has been
recommended by Boris a brook in sd4 book
this he recommended this g3 set up and
always also advocated for h4 at some
stage but not i'm not sure that it's
this position or something simular yeah
this is very straightforward you really
nighty 6l possible lady 64 to move maybe
okay not not show me how to proceed you
I wait maybe I could connect with a
fourth I can keep like inside me okay I
was just taking queen a 4 97 96 or
something could be very embarrassing but
I have queen d 7 it's a bit weird have
to cancel okay but now I can cast all
right but should i cancel I mean maybe
he's in playing a 45 I can I can play
the standard color move first maybe see
what is coming up with at least I'm
making it difficult for him to develop
them the queenside b3 i can take c 3
enter he moves the bishop I have not XP
to at least he needs to worry about that
d 1 yeah it's nothing Flint direct I
think that I can do but at least the
ruckus away from their farm
so if I castle I don't need to fear the
airport probably I didn't need to feel
it anyway but you never know okay he's
still not really threatening to move the
bishop I hope when I can at least take
it giving me two bishops hmm yeah I
quite like this position maybe maybe he
has got some tactical still some stuff
here on the King this age five is not a
great move I mean this the sole
construction is always vulnerable to
something sacrificing on g6 on f7 and so
on very often than not objectively
working but dangerous at the moment it
really it really doesn't look like
there's something going on in this wave
so let's put should I put ya set up the
usual kind of active position
ah this is nice maybe I can get an ID
for Bishop g4 or something right over
right out of the Bangko textbook but
can't really before are you intending
before maybe okay but you know there is
no direct no direct refutation of this
it's an ID for an idea and Bishop
default I don't know
and let's do that I'm I really don't
want to spend ages here it's probably
not the best move the night looked nice
on e5
still it not still it is not easy for
him to to move anything now I know this
is weird threatening Bishop b3 now it is
light squared Bishop was a was a useful
piece okay some tactical here I really I
must take this okay so it's trying to
try to consolidate if i go here I'm
threatening queen f2 and what about
capturing one sees I can take with the
bishop okay the queen is also but
there's noone rook a to at some point
yeah there's more than one good move ok
this is this is a simple the simple move
but then I was looking at some more
complicated things but this this is the
best one probably just picking up the
exchange
the atom immediately threatening night
look too unfortunately I cannot take on
g3 now but ok we could be too look Sam
quite nice as well white resigns yeah
but I even have rook h2h legs so
everything some coming here coming at
the same time yum yeah look pretty
pretty decent benko game I'm I'm not
sure if this is so great but i don't i
don't really know them ins and outs of
this opening precisely ah yeah the
computer immediately points out 96 yeah
i had some you know i mentioned it 96
it's really working ok let's look at
this I had some some doubts here and
it's really working ok takes GI takes I
need to go here yeah yeah okay it looks
dangerous and the rook here this is a
problem hey it's just a double check
basically it's threatening a mate and
it's attacking the rook and this one's
my twins with 96 yeah I I had someone
wake doubts about my position but it was
really working here at he castled after
that I guess the the worst is probably
over a couple of moves later already had
had an excellent compensation this is
like a dream banco i think every piece
is active and he can hardly move
anything on the queenside you know
computer wants to take him
yeah this is the easy solution getting a
pawn back with a good position them but
I didn't consider that I wanted to
activate our pieces and here this is
already lost yet the Solstice is so
strong you can keep the material but it
leads to it leads to really really ugly
positions where black's pieces are ultra
active others even nazi form as much is
easier you know yeah it can happen
quickly if you choose some wrong setup
it can blow in your face quickly as wide
but ok the main thing was he could he
could win with 96 and exactly this
position here 94 96 and ended wins
alright thanks for watching